LET'S SEE HOW IT GOES
IN THE NEXT ROUND.
ARE YOU READY?
WHAT IS A LOOSEY?
- NOW, I SHOULD KNOW THIS.
A SMOKE.
ding!
- DAMN, THAT'S--
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
A SINGLE CIGARETTE.
- A LOOSE CIGARETTE.
ding!
- THAT IS CORRECT.
- A CIGARETTE.
ding!
- THAT IS CORRECT.
WHAT IS A LOOSEY?
- IS THAT A--
A WAY OF SAYING ORAL SEX?
buzz!
- NO, BUT WE SHOULD
START SAYING THAT.
WHAT IS A LOOSEY?
- ONE CIGARETTE BOUGHT
AT THE STORE FROM THE ARABS.
ding!
- THAT IS CORRECT.
A CIGARETTE BOUGHT
AT THE STORE,
ONE LOOSE CIGARETTE,
FROM AN ARAB.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
- WHAT IS A CHICKENHEAD?
- THAT'S A WOMAN
WHO PUTS HER MOUTH
ON THE MEMBER OF A--
OR SOMETIMES CALLED
A CRACK WHORE.
ding!
- THAT IS ACCEPTABLE.
THAT IS ONE OF THE MANY
DEFINITIONS OF A CHICKENHEAD,
A FELLATIOUS WOMAN.
THERE WE GO.
MARK, THINGS ARE LOOKING UP.
- LET'S SEE.
SOMEBODY ON TV
USED TO SAY CHICKENHEAD.
"YOU'RE SUCH A CHICKENHEAD."
- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT SHOW THIS IS,
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE IT.
- SOMEBODY WHO'S STUPID.
buzz!
- NO, A CHICKENHEAD
IS A HOOCHIE, WHORE,
OR A FELLATIOUS WOMAN,
APPARENTLY.
- IT CAN BE USED
FOR DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT'S MOSTLY USED TO DESCRIBE
A HO OR AN UGLY WOMAN.
- A WOMAN THAT LIKES
TO SUCK PENIS.
A WOMAN THAT LIKES
- TO GIVE A LOOSEY.
- THAT'S RIGHT,
TO GIVE A LOOSEY.
WHAT IS A CHICKENHEAD?
- OH, YOU CAN FIND THAT ANYWHERE
IN THE HOOD, ON THE BLOCK.
IT'S A BIRD,
ONE OF THOSE THAT YOU JUST
BRING HOME AND WEAR OUT.
ding!
- THAT IS CORRECT.
A BIRD THAT YOU BRING HOME
AND WEAR OUT.
THAT IS CORRECT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE FOR.
THAT'S HOW THEY'RE USED.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
- FINISH THIS
GOOD TIME LYRIC:
"TEMPORARY LAYOFFS,
GOOD TIMES.
"EASY CREDIT RIP-OFFS,
"GOOD TIMES.
"SCRATCHING AND SURVIVING,
"BLANK,
GOOD TIMES."
- I KNOW THAT ONE CHARACTER
ON GOOD TIMES
WAS J.J. WALKER.
- THAT'S VERY GOOD.
I GET MISTAKEN FOR HIM A LOT
IN SHOPPING MALLS.
- ANOTHER ACTRESS
ON GOOD TIMES
IS LENNY KRAVITZ'S MOTHER.
buzz!
- OH, I'M SORRY,
THAT WAS THE JEFFERSONS,
BUT CLOSE.
both: ♪ EASY CREDIT RIP-OFFS ♪
♪ GOOD TIMES ♪
♪ SCRATCHING AND SURVIVING ♪
- ♪ GOOD TIMES ♪
[humming]
♪ GOOD TIMES ♪
- DAMN.
both:
♪ AIN'T WE LUCKY WE GOT 'EM ♪
- ♪ GOOD TIMES ♪
- YEAH, I...
- I REMEMBER WHEN WILLIS
HAD A DRINKING PROBLEM.
buzz!
- "SCRATCHING
AND SURVIVING,
"GOOD TIMES.
"BLANK,
GOOD TIMES."
- MM-HMM, AND I'VE ALWAYS
WONDERED THIS MYSELF.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
"HANGIN' IN A JURY,"
BUT IT'S--
IT'S--IT'S--AND IS IT A--
- SAY IT ONE MORE TIME.
SAY WHAT YOU JUST SAID
ONE MORE TIME.
- ♪ HANGIN' IN A JURY ♪
UM, AND I ALWAYS THOUGHT,
AS A KID,
"DOES THAT MEAN THAT SOMEONE
IS HUNG IN A JURY?"
BUT I DIDN'T--
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SAY
YOU CAN TELL
I KNOW THE ACTUAL SONG,
BUT THOSE ONES, I NEVER
COULD DECIPHER WHAT IT WAS.
IT WAS A--
- BRYAN TUCKER JUST POINTED OUT
A FACT THAT IS VERY TRUE.
THIS IS THE MOST DISPUTED LYRIC
IN ALL
OF THE GOOD TIMES LYRICS.
- YES.
- I AM INCLINED
TO GIVE HIM THE POINT.
I LOOK AT MY JUDGES--
ding!
HE GETS THE POINT.
- ALL RIGHT,
AND WHAT IS THE LYRIC?
- THE CORRECT LYRIC:
"HANGIN' IN A CHOW LINE."
I HAD TO LOOK IT UP
ON THE INTERNET MYSELF.
I THOUGHT IT WAS
"HANGIN' A JACKET."
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
- AND NOW
FOR THE FINAL QUESTION.
ARE YOU READY?
- I'M READY.
- HOW CAN BLACK PEOPLE
RISE UP AND OVERCOME?
- HOW CAN THEY RISE UP
AND OVERCOME?
WELL, CAN THEY OVERCOME?
NO, I'M JUST-.
ding!
- THAT IS CORRECT.
- [laughs]
- REPARATIONS.
ding!
- THAT IS ACCEPTABLE.
- THIS IS A RAP LYRIC?
- NO, THIS--I'M SORRY.
- OH, THIS IS
A GENERAL QUESTION.
- THIS IS AN ACTUAL QUESTION.
- ALL RIGHT.
THERE'S A COMPLEX ANSWER THERE.
ding!
- THAT IS CORRECT.
- STAYING ALIVE.
ding!
- THAT IS CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT.
- WELL, STOP CUTTIN'
EACH OTHER'S THROAT.
ding!
- THAT ALSO IS CORRECT.
HOW CAN BLACK PEOPLE
RISE UP AND OVERCOME?
- GET OUT AND VOTE.
buzz!
- THAT IS INCORRECT,
I'M AFRAID.
- [laughing]
- I'M SORRY.
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!
- WELL, FOLKS, OUR JUDGES
TALLIED UP THE SCORES,
AND WE HAVE A WINNER.
ROB THE DJ.
ROB, COME ON OUT.
EXCELLENT JOB, ROB.
CONGRATULATIONS.
HERE'S THE GRAND PRIZE.
OF COURSE, IT CONTAINS
A LIFETIME SUPPLY
OF MURRAY'S HAIR CREAM.
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND ONE CAN IS
A LIFETIME SUPPLY, TRUST ME.
TWO BOOTLEG DVDs.
AND, OF COURSE,
WHAT WOULD A GRAND PRIZE BE
WITHOUT A PACK
OF MENTHOL CIGARETTES?
[people shouting]
BLACK PEOPLE!